[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is like
the video and comment
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about everything we know about the
fifth episode of season 8
the battle of king's landing and for the
arm support with trailers teasers leaked
photos and previews
before we take a look on many leaked
photos and so much information we know
about episode 5
and the battle of king's landing where
we can see how danny's firing blood will
look like
as well as how king's landing will look
like after it's all done and over
let's firstly take a look on the trailer
for that episode
there's some huge things that you might
have missed if not paying close
attention
such as jaime being on a trial at
dragonstone but also jaime sneaking up
inside king's laning later on
here in this shot you can see a hooded
man passing through the golden company
as they march out of king's landing to
face the upcoming danish forces
that hooded man is jaime lannister it's
the same cloak and hood he had been
arriving in middle fell
and now he's got it when arriving at
king's landing while the golden company
marches outside the red cape jaime is
heading towards it to face his sister
cersei i'm really interested to see how
the entire jaime story plays out in the
next episode
i really hope jaime is not coming to try
and save cersei as brienne concluded he
was then leaving vanerfell
but i rather hope he is going to or at
least try to stop the
queen from doing any more damage than
what she already did
however before jaime arrives at king's
laning which i assume will not be in the
very beginning of an episode
because here the golden company is
marching out to face dany's armies led
by jon and tyrion
and from the preview we know tyrion will
be at dragonstone before going to king's
landing
so this scene is probably taking place
somewhere in the middle of an episode or
even at the end of it
anyways jaime will also most likely be
at dragonstone before arriving at king's
landing
here in the shot we can see tirion and
on the right amended by his posture and
figure does seem to look like jaime
in fact i'm quite certain it's jaime how
he ended up here
i doubt he came by his ville as he was
going to the capital and not to
dragonstone
so i'm assuming it's danish forces that
captured jaime
tyrion's worried face expression is what
seals the deal for me it's jaime with
danny tyrion in the dragonstone throne
room
and it's jaime is another trial this
time he cannot pull off i'm fighting for
the living card
and then he will most likely imprison
him however we do see jaime a bit later
sneaking inside king's landing
how i think jaime ended up from jungle
some dungeons to here is that tyrion
probably saved him
like jaime saved him back when tirion
was locked up invading his punishment
no way is tyrion gonna allow dany to
execute jaime i think tyrion instead
jaime free
and it will probably put tirion in quite
a trouble later on
okay now let's focus on the battle of
king's landing and leaked photos we have
from king's landing set
at the end of episode 4 cersei chose
violence over negotiations
and killed one of dany's best friends
and most loyal advisors
it was the perfect way to set up the
hype and thirst of vengeance for us the
viewers
but also for dany sirs evoke the dragon
and she will suffer the consequences in
episode 5 fire and blood
dany has lost almost everything and if
cersei thinks she's safe just because
she invited citizens to side red cape
she's up for a big surprise
as missandei's last word said jokaris i
can guarantee you danny and the unsolid
will go
on an execution spring king's landing
they will only show the him on cersei
but unfortunately i think that will be
exactly what cersei wanted
if cersei didn't want dany to attack
king's landing and red keep
but rather wanted to end the war some
other way cersei would not have beheaded
miss sandy
cersei wants dany to attack and we'll
find out why exactly in the upcoming
episode
qyburn does say to tyrion that cersei is
fully confident she is in better
position to win this war
as skybran pointed out cersei has
stronger army and many scorpions to kill
dragon
i think cersei has worked out this
entire plane in her head
and will now watch it play out perhaps
she wants dany to unleash drogon and
start burning king's landing
bringing cersei opportunity to use many
qyburn scorpions to bring her lash
dragon down
and then use the golden company lane
search and enormous forces to deal with
the remains of denny's forces
or perhaps she intends to get him all
fighting inside a capital and then burn
them all with wildfire
one way or another cersei's face
expression she gives dany after killing
miss said is basically telling dany your
move now
it just feels like she wants them to
attack right there at that moment
as expected cersei worked hard on pr in
king's landing
and made the small folks see dany as a
conqueror rather than a liberator
the army of the dead is a myth for them
a lie
cersei also invited all the small folk
to hide behind their walls
earning their loyalty when in reality
she's inviting them inside to use them
as a shield from danny and her dragons
going into episode 5 it's a lose-lose
situation for dany
as with whatever plan she makes she
cannot please anyone
she just lost her child her dragon
rhaegal and her best friend miss sandy
which could have been avoided if she had
decided to storm king's landing in
season 7
but she hadn't because she did not want
many innocent people to die
now dane is left with no choice but to
kill cersei which will unfortunately
take many small folk lives along
she tried to negotiate she tried
everything and all she's got in return
was losing almost everyone she cares
about
then is going to burn neurosplit in
episode 5. but urine and his fluid will
not be the only thing that's going down
burning
most of king's landing will as well
cersei is hiding inside the red keep and
got herself surrounded by the small folk
denny's got no choice but to burn the
red keep even if it means many innocent
people would die along
and she will in episode 5 as leaked
photos seem to be confirming
i'm a bit upset knowing that after this
many will declare dany the mad queen
which is definitely not even if she ends
up burning entire king's landing is
justified
she tried everything to avoid it she did
not want to do it back in season 7
when she thought there might be other
better solutions to avoid many civilian
casualties
but now there really is none then he's
got to kill her enemies
and that does not make her the mad queen
aegon the conqueror burned many castles
to the ground
ended up many houses which of course
killed many innocent people along
as he usually goes with every war but
you don't see people calling him the mad
king
everything dany can do now is try to
burn the red keep before drogon gets
killed by those many scorpions on king's
landing walls
leaked photos confirmed that many parts
of king's landing will indeed be burned
down by dragonfire
but i think drogon the last dragon will
get killed in the process
unfortunately i think dany will manage
to burn down the entire euros fleet
that is just outside king's landing and
waiting for her without jones getting
shot
however i do think dragon will get hit
by one of many scorpions placed on
king's landing malls
league photos confirmed that the last
war will be the fall of the capital
king's landing will burn for the final
season of game of thrones the production
for the very first time instead of
filming king's landing scenes in
jubronic
they decided to make a huge king's
landing set in belfast and film most of
the scenes there
all king's laning shots you saw in
episode 4 were filmed on that set
it's not a real city it's a huge
enormous set the reason they built that
set is so they can burn it down
that's the reason they had to build this
huge set rather than film all the scenes
seemed to browning
it's not just the city walls the set is
far bigger than that
the crew built a whole city street at
one end there's the gate
and at the other end the front of the
red keep in between there are all types
of different buildings
the most notable are the city gates and
king's landing dome
however as you can see in these leaked
photos the set was later burned down
with a huge bridge between demolished
towers
the city gate has been obliterated and
the towers that once protected it have
fallen
danny using jorgen has seemingly burned
down huge portions of the capital
including his landing dome i'm not
saying cersei will not use wildfire
beneath the capital to burn everything
down as she realizes she's lost the war
which she could have done via cgi but
the damage done on king's laning set is
coming from danny and her dragons
it's a well-known fact that the show
built a king's laning set mainly to do
live power techniques
it means that some parts of the capital
will be burned down by a dragon as
dragon fire in game of thrones is
portrayed by live fire techniques
let's go party in the hound who will
also be at the capital in the next
episode escape before drogon arrives
danish dragon that is responsible for a
huge portion of the capital being burned
down was spotted on this king's landing
set
what this means is that dany will
probably land at king's landing either
because jorgen is mortally wounded and
cannot fly anymore
or she decides to land after she's
burned everything down
in case you're not really into filming
and behind the scenes clips let me
remind you that if actors have to mount
or dismount a dragon
part of its spine has to be physically
recreated which is exactly what this
massive contraption on king's landing
set is
this massive conception being on this
very same set means that dany will at
some point decide to land in king's
landing
we have all known that jaguars would
eventually fly over king's landing
as bran saw it in his vision of the
future and we now know for a fact it's
dany riding shogun
just the moments before she unleashes
her vengeance on the red keep
i believe danny will burn down the red
keep killing cersei and finally ending
her reign
i'm just going to be upset that some
people probably including ethereum varys
and jon
will be observing dany killing many
innocent people along
but then he really doesn't have a choice
danny will burn down euron's fleet and
the red keep
killing cersei but also most likely
killing jaime as well
who will be with cersei it seems that
after all cersei will be a woman he
loves and is whose arms he dies
regarding the battle outside the city
walls between the golden company and
dennis
and jaron's remaining forces led by jon
i don't think there will be a battle
i don't think the golden company will
fight against aegon targaryen
i believe there will be a twist and the
golden company will actually alive
themselves to jon
in the books they only lied to the
person they thought was the real heir of
the armed throne
the so-called aegon i think varys will
send them a word of josh to identity
where upon they will switch sides since
fair loyalty to jon snow they are just
outside king's landing
conlet hill and actor who plays various
thieves that verse will be as effective
as
always in season 8. what is means and
for shadows in my opinion is that varys
will turn the golden company against
cersei yearn
persuading them to fight for the last
raker son a gun targaryen
we have been listening over and over
again how the golden company have never
broken a contract
that them breaking it and supporting
targaryens seems like such an obvious
twist of the final season
additionally the golden company have
already broken a contract in the books
and you guessed who was the reason a
targaryen named aegon
in conclusion episode 5 the battle of
the armed round will be one epic episode
and one cannot wait for sunday then it
comes with fire and blood
jaime comes for cersei king's landing
will burn and the golden company will
probably betray cersei
and side with jon snow upon finding out
his true name is aegon targaryen
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace